you ever hear some news and then your
answer your thought is like all right
well we'll see how it goes in the course
of the next couple days that thought
grows you have more thoughts and it
becomes an itch a voice in your head
that's just not going to shut up unless
you do a YouTube video about it and put
it out there in the universe
right
if you haven't guessed this what
happened to me right so it was announced
a couple days ago that a new season of
Daredevil is coming to Disney plus could
be a new series of Daredevil it's kind
of unclear as to whether or not this is
going to be Daredevil season four that
takes place after the Netflix series
Daredevil or a new Daredevil series
entirely in which Charlie Cox reprises
his role as Matt Murdock you probably
have the returning cash show up again
spoilers for Hawkeye in three two one
you've been warned Vincent D'Onofrio who
played Wilson Fisk in the Daredevil
series who was also Wilson Fisk in the
Hawkeye series reprises his role as
Wilson Fisk it's unclear but really it's
neither here nor there the question is
whether or not this is going to feel
like the Netflix series that Daredevil
was hence my concern and to address
something right out the gate I've seen
it I've seen the chatter in the comment
sections I've I've read the room so to
speak I've even experienced it myself
the MCU now doesn't feel like the MCU as
it was leading up to that event of
infinity war and you can pass it off as
well it's really this phase has kind of
been unclear other than Multiverse
that's fun you could still make that
work you just need compelling
storytelling compelling characters good
writing you know the works the things
that the MCU used to thrive on therein
lies my concern with what I feel like
the mcu's problem right now is I feel
like it's a problem with
complacency I did a couple binges which
really leads to me doing this video if I
hadn't binged these couple things I
probably wouldn't be doing a video right
now but recently enough I binged the
Daredevil Netflix series which funny
enough is on Disney plus right now but
still same series and the phase one MCU
films like before they were going after
Infinity Stones when they were building
towards the Avengers movie that was a
big thing they were building towards and
if you haven't watched The Phase One MCU
films recently you should especially
with 2022 goggles it's a really
interesting watch because what I feel
made the MCU Thrive back in phase one
was what made Daredevil thrive on
Netflix they were both stories that I
feel
felt like they had to earn the
audience's trust MCU phase one they were
like we have a dream we dropped the
Avengers Initiative in this post-credits
scene of Iron Man before post-credit
scenes were normal
and here's hoping but now we have to
prove that we can pull that Vision off I
feel like the same with Daredevil the
MCU was a name at that point but still a
series of Marvel characters and
Daredevil Daredevil's not the deepest
cut ever but he's not Spider-Man or
Wolverine plus a lot of us saw the Ben
Affleck movie before so who was gonna
get excited but whereas in phase one of
the MCU Marvel Studios they still need
to Paramount to put their [ __ ] out they
had to try they were The Underdogs they
felt like they had to earn their place
and that kind of weight on your
shoulders can lead to some great product
now Marvel Studios is the biggest thing
on earth I mean in terms of the Cinema
Scene anyway we've now gotten to a place
when someone is cast in an MCU movie The
chatter online is oh I'm so glad they
landed a spot in the MCU that was never
the conversation for comic book movies
before the MCU became as big as it
became they don't have to try as hard
the Marvel name will generally sell the
product and there is no bigger impedance
to create creativity
the net mindset there's a part of me
that's just accepted that fact I don't I
don't beat my head against the wall
about it I understand that the MCU will
never be as great as it was with
infinity War We're not gonna get that
kind of thing again had a solid sweet
epic 10-year climb to this event and I'm
completely satisfied with it I've
accepted the fact that the MCU is gonna
try new things now I totally get it it's
not going to feel as epic as it felt
before I just take it as it comes but I
guess my indifference has a line and
that line is Daredevil because this is a
this is Daredevil Daredevil was a show
that elevated the live-action comic book
series to a degree I hadn't seen since
Heroes on o6 before it it's a drama
that's wearing a mask It's a drama
masquerading as a superhero show it's
that thing if you're dating somebody
who's just into Super artsy stuff I
speak from experience Daredevil's one of
those shows you could look at that
person and honestly be like
I think I think we should watch
Daredevil I think he would like it and
you might very well be right about that
you know Daredevil was a different thing
entirely hence my concern and my concern
comes from the fact that the MCU Cinema
series or otherwise has never produced
something like Daredevil it's just never
produced anything that has the same
Daredevil vibe that feel that tone
closest they could have come was Moon
Knight you know Moon Knight could have
been that thing you know I mean it was a
psychological Thriller could have been a
psychological Thriller it's a different
thing my point is when Moon Knight
looked like it was gonna push it and
become something different something new
for the MCU or an MCU series second
panicked and it went to the MCU safe
Zone even that scene where he's going
crazy he's in the hospital the lighting
was all off it was too well lit then you
had a talking hippo that talked like a
gen Z tick tocker I'm just I know that's
that's my old man moment cheers I feel
like they're gonna go to the MCU safe
Zone with the Daredevil series or you
take will Wilson Fisk from Hawkeye right
so Wilson Fisk from Hawkeye full
transparency I haven't seen Hawkeye I
was just so jacked after my Daredevil
binge I was like I want to see more
D'Onofrio as Wilson Fisk all right oh
hey I know who the villain in Hawkeye is
all right let's just skip so I skipped
at the Kingpin scenes and it was just
very different first of all Wilson Fisk
in the Netflix Daredevil series would
never wear that herb muddle foot shirt
with a Blazer he would find it tacky
it's just what is that glad he has his
Cane you know that kind of takes me back
also if you got that herb muddle foot
reference cheers baby but Daredevil
season 3 ends off with this amazingly
violent and visceral moment I beat you
right that's how Wilson Fisk goes down
how does he go down in Hawkeye Kate
Bishop flicks a cufflink like Johnny
Lawrence flicks a bottle cap hits an
arrowhead they all explode and he goes
down that's a very clean yet Grandin
spectacle mcuified way of doing it you
line up those two that's the difference
between Daredevil tone and MCU tone it's
just a case of x expecting someone to
produce a different product than what
they've produced for the past decade or
so that's just that's ridiculous so
expecting that Daredevil will feel like
the Netflix Daredevil series is just I'm
not there odds are they're gonna take
that something and Annex it into the
tone that they do it being MCU tone not
Daredevil tone and I know the counter
argument that I've seen online is that
the Netflix Marvel series you know
Jessica Jones Luke Cage Iron Fist
Defenders Daredevil they're all on
Disney plus right now but to me I I
don't see it as anything other than a
brilliant move where they're like okay
we want these on Disney plus so people
can associate the brand with us now
instead of Netflix and then we'll create
our our new Daredevil series I kind of
see it as a family of people and that
family in that house they they kind of
have a tone A vibe to them but maybe
they want a couple hundred more bucks a
month and they have an extra room in the
house so they rent that room to this
other roommate that I think is how the
Netflix Marvel series fit onto Disney
plus they see it as roommate but it's
not family but it's a [ __ ] cool
roommate so that's my take that's where
I'm coming from I want to be excited
about this I want to see a season four
of Daredevil but something tells me
they'll just be like nah it's like a new
Daredevil From Another Universe because
you know Multiverse all right so a new
Daredevil series coming to Disney plus
that's now part of the MCU are you
excited are you concerned what are your
thoughts about it do you agree with me
do you think I'm being ridiculous
regardless of the bus fire that is
social media and the internet anywhere
else we still maintain civil
conversation here because we're here
talking about entertainment seeing
entertainment as it is
entertainment whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]